ما تزال جماعه الاخوان في فرنسا والتنظيم
العالي الذي تعمل به موضع اهتمام اجهزه
الاستخبارات الفرنسيه صحيفه لوفيجارو كشفت
عن قيام المديريه العامه للامن الداخلي
بتحديد صناديق اوقاف مرتبطه بالجماعه تقوم
باستثمار غير قانوني لاموال تصرف على
نشاطاتها هذه التحقيقات افضت الى تجميد ما
يقرب من 25 مليون يورو كانت مجموعه في 20
صندوق هبات انشئت عام 2008 وعملت على
اخفاء دوائر تمويل الجماعه لحظ ان هناك
تاخر من قبل السلطات الفرنسيه لسببين
السبب الاول
شيء من السذاجه في ادراك خطورات هذا
المنهاج ثانيا الزبونيه السياسيه في فرنسا
التي تشجع
كسب اصوات الناخبين المسلمين
الطويله والدقيقه التي تم اجراؤها من قبل
اجهزه الاستخبارات الفرنسيه تكشف عن اليه
تمويل غامضه ومعقده بشده لكنها سمحت في
النهايه بتنفيذ ما اسمتها الصحيفه اجراءات
عرقله في غايه السريه واستهدفت حتى الان
ثمانيه صناديق من اصل الصناديق العشرين هي
تستفيد من المنظومه الفرنسيه مثلا في
التمويل العامه مثلا في حملات لمكافحه
اسلاموفوبيا لكن في المقابل يلجا
المستهدفون بهذه الاجراءات الى مسارات
قضائيه واحيانا الى توظيف علاقات سياسيه
مع مسؤولين من اقصى اليسار ويضحضون
علاقاتهم مع الجماعه بالقول انهم ضحايا
حمله كراهيه تشنها اجهزه من الدوله
الفرنسيه
وحدد جهاز الاستخبارات الاقليميه نحو 20
مدن اظهرت ما تسميها مذكرات استخ اشارات
مبكره على التطرف هذه المدن تشهد نشاطات
مختلفه لجماعه الاخوان على محور يمتد من
مارسيليا جنوبيه البلاد مرورا بالعاصمه
باريس ووصولا الى مدينه ليل الشماليه
فرنسا فدده العربيه باريس لمتابعه المزيد
من الاخبار والبرامج وال
قصص والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات